all right so it's never really clear
when the right time is to make
announcements about show related changes
but I think I'm gonna do that today why
not right so a little backstory the
David Pakman show moved to Boston in
November of 2015 we signed a three-year
lease at our studio and that has been to
take a word from our current president's
vocabulary it has been a beleaguered
experience with this three-year lease at
our current studio we have had terrible
internet thanks at least in part to the
Internet service provider monopoly
industrial complex that most parts of
the United States experience we had
almost three full years of construction
happening around us and constant
negotiations and arguments and
disagreements and tension with the
landlord's that managed the building not
to mention the sort of daily clumping as
we have come to refer to it taking place
above us at the studio so we we are not
exactly in what we would call a good
studio situation and even with all of
that stuff aside we're not in what one
would call like a modern building or one
that's technologically advanced it's not
just that the Internet infrastructure in
our building is bad the electrical
system is outdated even the sort of
basic construction is outdated massive
sound transfer not just from the noise
above us but side-to-side from outside
the building from below so long story
short and many of our members know this
because we talk about it on the bonus
show it's been a nightmare at our
current studio we've also been working
kind of at the same time on upgrading
the production quality of the David
Pakman show when it comes to image and
audio quality and the benefits of those
upgrades would sort of be irrelevant
unless we can solve the noise around us
issue and solve the Internet bandwidth
issues that we're dealing with so the
big announcement is that the david
pakman show is indeed going to be
leaving a current David Pakman show
headquarters now once we leave it won't
david pakman show headquarters anymore
but that's sort of like a semantic
discussion which we can have some other
time I want to stick to the important
things during during this segment so we
are indeed going to be leaving the
current studio and leaving that part of
Boston at the end of our lease or maybe
within the last month of that where are
we going to go we are going to go to
Calgary Alberta no I'm kidding we're
staying in Boston the David Pakman show
is not changing location in terms of
city or state but we are going to be
going to a truly state-of-the-art
facility a building that has been
completely gutted and renovated to be a
place for technology companies and
endeavors it's been built that way from
the ground up we are going to have I am
extraordinarily pleased to say people
who get the bonus show already know how
much pleasure I take in telling you that
we are going to have what is within
reason the fastest internet available in
Boston and I say within reason because
if we were willing to pay a thousand or
two thousand dollars a month for a
dedicated fiber connection plus the
installation of the infrastructure we
could probably get faster internet but
putting that aside we are going to have
colloquially speaking generally speaking
the fastest internet available in the
city we are going to have a properly
sound proofed and sound insulated studio
with the most modern power
infrastructure that is available and as
usually is the case with these
transitions there's going to be an
interim period that might be sort of
like a step back before we go several
steps forward but the long term is going
to be very good for the show so what I
am announcing today is a $100,000
IndieGoGo campaign I'm kidding we're not
doing that we've actually gone about
this a different way this time we have
decided to partner with some too in fact
strategic longtime supporters of the
show with the idea that
if we build it support will follow if
the program improves and becomes more
professional and better that support is
going to follow so in the last few
months as some of you may know you might
have thought that when I said were
scrapping a bunch of advertisers and
we're extending the show 10% every
single day that it was just for kicks
that's not the case that was part of
this broader upgrade an expansion of the
David Pakman show
so we've fronted the costs of the studio
transition including build-out but also
security deposits and prepaid rent all
of that stuff and what I'm asking of you
is that if you want to support us in
this expansion and transition if you
value what we do and want to help us do
it better and in a more professional way
we've partnered with two very generous
longtime supporters who are willing to
donate $30 every time that a new person
gets a yearly membership at half price
for $30 so in total each of these
supporters is willing to do a hundred of
these so 200 people in total can get a
membership instead of paying $60 you pay
30 but these two generous longtime
supporters are going to send us an
additional $30 this is like 10 cents per
hour long daily episode if you want to
slice it up that way
$30 for the year and you can keep that
discounted price for as long as you want
and we get an additional $30 for every
person that signs up using a particular
coupon code how do you do it you just
have to email me okay email me you can
either go to david pakman.com and click
on the contact form I am this is so
important what we're doing is just so so
important I'm personally handling these
requests for these discounted membership
so you can go to our website or you can
email me directly david at david
pakman.com either way i will be your
personal membership concierge that's how
important this is
say hey David I want one of those half
priced memberships $30 if you get one of
those fancy lattes per month you're
spending more in a year on those than
what a full year of membership will cost
you membership continues to be the
number one funding source for our
program and instead of doing a
fundraising campaign in advance and
saying here's the things we want to do
we've done it okay
during October the transition is going
to happen the money's been spent the
deposits have been done rent has been
prepaid equipment and all sorts of
different things have been purchased and
what now I'm asking you to do is to say
hey you know what this David Pakman show
thing it's here and it's going to
improve and it's going to grow I'm going
to do my part 10 cents an episode get in
touch david at david pakman.com I will
get you that coupon code to get the half
price membership if the show is as
valuable to you as one latte per month
for a year is please consider getting in
touch and getting that code and I will I
look forward to hopefully telling you
about the success of this campaign